ROGER MARTINEZ: Hey, Roger
here from Google Cloud.
And in this video,
we'll have a look
at how developers can
extend G Suite to build
seamless solutions enabling
users of popular tools
like Gmail, Chat, and Drive
to work faster, easier,
and smarter.
Specifically, we'll
look at an end
to end solution that
highlights newer developer
technologies like
G Suite add-ons,
Chatbots, and accelerated
mobile pages for email.
By showcasing different
types of integrations
that developers can
build with G Suite,
we hope to inspire
you to build your own.
So let's get started.
Meet Anu, the manager
of a customer service
team at another corp.
She receives an email
from one of her
customers, AltoStrat,
who wants help resolving
a nagging issue,
inconsistent access
to the payment portal.
Obviously, resolving this
in a timely manner is key.
In the email from
the customer, we
can see a couple of key pieces
of information, the issue
number, and, of course,
the customer name.
As a developer, you can
leverage that information
in the context of the email
to build applications that
can really benefit the manager.
Here, we can see
how Anu launches her
CRM add-on in Gmail.
Without having to
switch applications, log
into another system, and
risk losing focus and flow,
she can quickly
triage the customer
to see important details such
as key contacts and the type
of service contract
that they have.
Next, still within the
CRM add-on in Gmail,
Anu can see that
AltoStrat is also
an important sales
prospect with a couple
of big deals on the table.
Now that Anu understands
the customer better,
it's time to dig in on the
issue that they're having.
Anu has another add-on
available in Gmail
where she can quickly
understand the history
and status of the issue.
Note, the add-on used the
context of the issue number
from the email so Anu didn't
have to retype it or look it up
in another system.
With a closer
look, Anu discovers
that the issue had
been open in the past,
but was not yet assigned to
a technician to resolve it.
In order to get
this back on track,
Anu takes action to
escalate the issue
and receive immediate
attention by changing
its priority to a critical
P0 right within the add-on.
Anu can also add an explanation
of the changes in a custom
comment.
Now she needs to assign
someone to cover the issue.
Given the urgency, sending
out an email to the team
may not be fast enough.
So, while still
within Gmail, Anu
switches over to using Chat
to quickly reach everyone
in the customer care
team via their chat room.
Anu invokes the
team's Kanban Chatbot
with a simple at mention.
And the custom built
chatbot responds
to everyone's availability,
pulling from the team's
resource planning back end app.
Quickly, Anu new sees that
Guru is not fully tasked
and pings him directly,
asking if he can help.
Once he confirms
that he can, Anu
uses another custom chat bot
to assign the task directly
to Guru from within the
conversation, making sure
that it's immediately
assigned and recorded.
Now that we've seen how Anu
was able to triage and assign
the issue, let's take a look
at how our customer service
rep can use G Suite extensions
to help resolve the customer
issue.
Now that the task
has been assigned
to Guru, when he
checks his inbox,
he sees the email notifying
him of the assignment.
However, the email itself
is a little unique.
As you can see here by the
lightning bolt designation,
it's a dynamic email,
which is using the AMP
for Email spec in Gmail.
What makes this
interesting is Guru
can interact with this
email much like he would
the issue tracking application.
But once again, without
having to leave his inbox.
For example, he can browse
the details of the issue,
see related documents
that might be useful,
and even review the history
of the issue up to that point.
Guru can quickly
see the comments
the manager added
when escalating
this issue for the customer.
Then, right inside
the email, Guru
can acknowledge that he
is accepting the issue
being assigned to him, saving
time and allowing the team
to know that he's
got it covered.
The power of the dynamic
email becomes very apparent.
As you can see,
Guru's acceptance
is instantly displayed in
the body and the activity
history of the original email.
There's even an
inline UI in the email
where Guru can leave
his own comment
where he logs that he has a
good idea of what the issue is.
When the issue tracking
generated this dynamic email,
it also added a folder
and provided a link
to the resolution template
using the Drive API,
saving the customer service
rep time in locating documents
while ensuring they use
the correct templates
and store them
correctly within Drive.
Now let's fast
forward to when Guru
has worked through the problem
and wants to record the process
and close out the issue.
The customer service
team Guru works in stores
all customer documents in a
shared drive on Google Drive.
It's here where
Guru will wrap up
the process of capturing steps
and outcomes of the issue.
But like we saw
before with Gmail
and how you can leverage
add-ons with contexts,
you can do the same with
Google Drive as well.
The same add-on
written and published
once works across all G Suite.
So after a quick scan of the doc
to make sure it's all complete,
Guru can access
the add-on in Drive
and change the status
to closed without ever
having to leave G Suite.
And that's it.
Problem solved.
As you can see, G Suite
enables developers
to provide solutions that can
integrate complex processes
and data seamlessly
into G Suite.
The solutions you can build
can reduce contact switching,
improve workflow, and make
it easier for users and teams
to get things done.
If you'd like to learn
more, check out the links
in the description below.
And don't forget, subscribe
to our YouTube channel
for more great content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]